credo nelle persone e credo nella forza
delle loro idee
per questo dopo aver trascorso tutta la
mia carriera nelle risorse umane
ho deciso di cambiare lavoro e tra tre
giorni aiuterò a far volare le idee
degli altri
non solo quelle grandi unicamente delle
aziende o delle start up ma anche quelle
più piccole quelle che abbiamo tutti noi
e che non lo sappiamo ancora ma possono
fare una grande differenza
oggi vi parlerò di un nemico di una
maledizione che tarpa le ali le nostre
idee e di cinque modi per sconfiggerla e
cambiare il mondo un'idea alla volta
viviamo in un mondo di grandi
rivoluzioni e solo negli ultimi anni
queste rivoluzioni hanno cambiato il
modo in cui noi siamo produttivi il modo
in cui ascoltiamo musica il modo in cui
ci relazioniamo gli uni gli altri
il modo in cui facciamo acquisti o il
modo in cui ci muoviamo viaggiamo questi
sono grandi rivoluzioni che hanno avuto
grandi finanziamenti ma vi posso
assicurare che le idee che cambiano il
mondo sono dappertutto e la maggior
parte delle volte sono piccole noi tutti
abbiamo idee ciascuno di questa idea può
fare un piccolo cambiamento che però può
toccare tante persone magari non milioni
come le app che abbiamo appena visto
magari un po di meno
magari anche su una persona sola anche
se fosse però una persona sola varrebbe
la pena di provare a far volare quella
idea
pensiamo per esempio a un gruppo di
dieci persone
una persona di questo gruppo trova un
modo di semplificare la vita a tutti gli
altri non è necessario che sia una cosa
rivoluzionaria può essere un documento
obsoleto che non va più usato un modo
diverso di archiviare le cose che ti fa
ripetere trovare i documenti in modo più
rapido
ecco mettiamo che questa innovazione
faccia risparmiare 5 minuti a ciascun
membro del team da 10 membri del team
sono 50 minuti sono 250 minuti alla
settimana 1000 minuti al mese
dodicimila minuti all'anno
dodicimila minuti sono 25 giorni
lavorativi si fanno un sacco di cose in
25 giorni
tra tv e tutto questo da una piccola
cosa da cinque minuti
questo perché come dice osho la vita non
è fatta di cose incredibili è fantastica
e fatte di piccole cose ma quando non
chiede l'impossibile quelle piccole cose
si trasformano in realtà eccezionali il
fatto è che noi non conosciamo il
potenziale delle nostre idee finché non
proviamo a farle volare non ci sediamo e
diciamo adesso trovo un modo per far
risparmiare 5 minuti ai miei compagni di
team o trovo il modo di risolvere la
viabilità della mia città o costruisco
un ape incredibile le idee nascono dal
nostro confronto con la realtà dalla
nostra voglia di migliorarla e cambiarla
e il modo in cui noi rispondiamo ai
problemi che la vita ci pone ora non
fraintendetemi non tutte le idee sono
geniali hanno avuto successo per esempio
vogliamo parlare di questa questa
bevanda rumena dal nome un po
stravagante qualcuno si ricorda
spero di no il gusto dei primi piatti
prodotti raccolga te o il gusto della
coca cola 2 o ha mai preso appunti
sull'apple newton
ecco anche la apple ha avuto idee che
non hanno volato
però l'importante è capire che se
vogliamo avere idee che volano dobbiamo
avere il coraggio di sbagliare dobbiamo
avere il coraggio di esporci e di
esporre la nostra idea al mondo
ho lavorato 16 anni nelle risorse umane
mi ha sempre colpito vedere quante
quanto le persone abbiano idee per
migliorare la loro vita lavorativa che
va da un processo aziendale alla
disposizione dell'area break e mi ha
colpito vedere quante volte la tengano
per loro stessi e non la comunicano agli
altri o peggio quante volte una buona
idea non ha spiccato il volo perché
comunicata male o presentata male e la
maggior parte delle volte la presentiamo
male per il nemico cui faceva accenno ma
l'inizio del top per quella maledizione
che prende tutti noi
si chiama la maledizione della
conoscenza
spiegata in dettaglio è quando sappiamo
qualcosa ci risulta difficile immaginare
come ci sentivamo quando non lo sapevamo
quindi quando noi spieghiamo qualcosa
diamo per scontato troppe cose
pensateci ci capita tutti i giorni
proviamo a spiegare l'idea un amico un
collega e diamo per scontato un termine
inglese abbiamo per scontato un termine
tecnico
diamo per scontato un acronimo per
esempio qualche anno fa un direttore
finanziario mi stava facendo vedere i
numeri chiave della società per la quale
lavoravamo e alla fine della
presentazione detto emanuele questi
naturalmente sono i numeri bau è mai
venuto vale rispondere mia oh
per fortuna non fatto bau è l'acronimo
inglese di business as usual
allo stato attuale del business però
anche quel direttore finanziario è stato
colpito dalla maledizione della
conoscenza dava per scontato che io
sapessi quella cosa ecco quando si
tratta delle nostre idee di farle volare
questa maledizione ancora più forte
perché sono nostre
ce l'abbiamo dentro quindi sono talmente
belle ne siamo talmente innamorati che
pensiamo che verranno corrisposte per
forza non è sempre così
ecco quindi cinque consigli nel nostro
amico fonzie per combattere la mille
miglia maledizione della conoscenza e
fare volare le nostre idee primo chi
sappiate sempre chi avete davanti quando
state presentando un idea non unicamente
dal punto di vista del ruolo che può
avere in azienda o dell'età anagrafica
ma proprio dal punto di vista della
vostra idea rispetto all'argomento che
state per trattare avete davanti una
platea di esperti o no perché una cosa
impiegare le nuvole dei metereologi
basterebbe far ricordare loro il ciclo
dell'acqua e sarebbe abbastanza facile
ma se le dovete spiegare dei bambini
questa risulterebbe un po difficile
meglio trovare qualcosa che sia più
vicino a loro
magari il vapore che esce dalla pentola
sulla quale la mamma stato
accendo la pasta e spiegare che quel
vapore simile al vapore acqueo che si
genera dal mare pensate alla semplicità
con cui francesca ci ha spiegato il dna
prima una volta che sapete che avete
davanti sapete anche perché dovrebbe
interessare la vostra idea non è certo
spiegandola nei dettagli che la farete
volare in alto
anzi resti spiegare i vantaggi che
l'idea genera e per chi sono quei
vantaggi
siete sempre voi che dovete adattarvi
alla vostra audience e non viceversa
2 semplicità in un mondo in cui
combattiamo per l'attenzione e mantenere
l'attenzione dell'audience difficile e
combattiamo contro whatsapp il
telefonini
lo schermo di un monitor la semplicità e
la chiarezza sono un vantaggio
incredibile quanto più un'idea espressa
in modo semplice quanto più volerà in
alto guardate per esempio il motore di
ricerca che usavamo noi tutti fino a 12
anni fa circa e guardate quello che
usiamo adesso la semplicità è sempre un
vantaggio
ricordatevi 3 emozioni
usate le vostre emozioni e in
particolare la passione la passione e
coinvolgente la passione cattura
l'attenzione molte volte è fatto anche
l'esempio alessandro lucchini nel primo
top ci sono persone che dicono
sono molto contento di essere qui al ted
ho la mia idea rivoluzionaria
ecco non fatelo se non ci credete voi
non ci crederà nessuno ve lo garantisco
usate la passione come qualcosa che fa
volare in alto le vostre idee
noi usiamo le nostre emozioni nella vita
per fare grandi cose usiamolo anche per
le nostre idee
4 provate
anzi provate provate provate molti
additano steve jobs come un grande
venditore di idee lui né fatte volare
veramente tante veramente in alto
l'apple newton all ha progettato lui
comunque
se volete detto i primi video di steve
jobs si era bravo ma non così bravo come
nelle ultime volte in cui ci ricordiamo
che presentava essere prodotti questo
perché prima del lancio lui si chiudeva
due o tre giorni questo ai collaboratori
più stretti e provava e riprovava l'idea
e continuava a provarla
finché non era semplice finché non era
chiara finché i passaggi non erano
semplicissimi in questo modo ha fatto
volare tante le sue idee
l'ultimo libertà una volta che fate
volare la vostra idea non è più vostro
può prendere traiettorie di volo che
sono insospettabili all'inizio può
essere anche presa da qualcun altro è
fatta volare in un altro modo
molte delle grandi idee che noi
conosciamo sono nate in un modo e sono
diventate qualcos'altro
il play doh per esempio la pasta da sale
che usano tutti i bambini è nata con il
detergente per i muri e il pluriball
quello che usiamo per impacchettare o
almeno così diciamo i nostri oggetti
preziosi invece stiamo lì a schiacciarlo
come dei matti
ecco è nato come carta da parati quindi
non siate gelosi delle vostre idee
lasciate le libere anche se avranno
volato poco con la sembianza che
volevate darli voi e sono state prese da
qualcun altro ha fatto un altro volo
avrete comunque partecipato a un grande
cambiamento quindi per riassumere 1
sappiate sempre chi avete davanti perché
dovrebbe interessare la vostra idea
siate il più semplici possibili usate le
emozioni e la passione in particolare
provate provate provate e liberate le
vostre idee
vorrei concludere con un esempio
personale
questo è il mio padre è morto due anni
fa dopo una lunga malattia e ha passato
gli ultimi giorni la sua vita in un
hospice le strutture ospedaliere dove ti
accolgono quando non c'è più nulla da
fare
ecco sulla porta di camera di mio padre
c'era l'immagine di una barca con
scritto sopra il suo nome non signor
mascherpa o giorgio mascherpa solo
giorgio come sulle altre camere
dell'hospice l'ho sempre trovato uno
stupendo gesto per personalizzare
umanizzare un ambiente
altrimenti pervaso dalla crudeltà della
morte e mi sono chiesto chissà che ha
avuto quella semplice idea semplicissima
un'immagine un nome e chissà quante
altre persone è stata di conforto per me
tutte quelle che magari frequentavano
quel luogo per trovare i loro cari che
stavano per lasciarli ecco piccolissima
idea
pensate a quante vedete voi invece e non
pensate mai che siano troppo piccole per
avere un effetto un impatto sugli altri
provate a farle volare usate questi
cinque consigli o trovate neanche altri
è una volta che ne farete volare una vi
verrà voglia di farne volare un'altra e
un'altra ancora e un'altra ancora perché
le idee sono un po come i cioccolatini
una tira l'altra
usate la passione e fatene volare il più
possibile perché come dice leonardo
quando camminerete sulla terra dopo aver
volato guarderete il cielo perché la
siete stati e la vorrebbe tornare grazie
[Applauso]